now the UK has confirmed a deal to work
with the United States and Australia to
build a new generation of nuclear attack
submarines join me now security minister
Tom tugenhart a good to see you Tom
um very well the these submarines of
course the orcas pack
all about strengthening relations
between Australia America and the UK but
also about looking at the threat that
Australia faces China very high up on
that threat is the UK government being a
bit soft on China at the moment do you
think no I think what you've just spoken
about actually is about the challenges
that we're seeing in the Pacific you
spoke about the North Pacific there
North Korea and you're quite right to
highlight some of the aspects on China
but this is actually about much more
than that this is about a demonstration
that democracies like ours like
Australia like the United States can
stand together against the challenges
that we're facing around the world now
you're quite right to highlight China
but there are others as well Iran and
Russia have all in different ways been
challenging the freedoms that we enjoy
to travel to trade to associate and
indeed to enjoy the liberty of allies
that have been threatened in places like
Ukraine and around the world so this is
hugely important and it will bring jobs
to Barrow it will bring strength and
depth to our nuclear and to our naval
fleets in not just the Pacific but
actually also the Indian Ocean and
indeed the Atlantic the fact that you're
bringing in other countries when we talk
about China it feels a little bit like
the government's saying
don't be too worried about China Lord
West not that long ago just on the 14th
of March said that is it is the the
number one threat and in his mind to
World stability do you not agree with
that well I think the integrated review
that was published yesterday makes that
extremely clear the Prime Minister
describes it an Epoch defining challenge
now that challenge comes in many
different ways you know you have heard
me speak about the threat and the
challenge that China poses in different
ways in different areas and you know in
recent months sadly I've had to work on
closing down some illegal Chinese police
stations here in the UK and making sure
that Chinese citizens who may be
studying here are not being threatened
by the Chinese State and making sure the
British citizens or British Nationals
including Hong kongers are free from
Chinese repression here in the United
Kingdom so this is a challenge that we
are facing at home and abroad and this
is absolutely not something that we're
in any way uh ignoring what it means
however is we must work with friends and
allies and that's why staying in line
with them and working alongside them is
so important that's why the language yes
it matters to make sure that we're
aligned with the United States and of
course Australia which is also about
what we do if you look at what this
package of measures includes you and
we've spoken about the nuclear votes and
they are very important but we're also
talking about doubling the amount of
money we're going to spend on
understanding China here in the United
Kingdom that means things like language
learning and understanding what's going
on in Beijing and we're also of course
talking about building up our friends
and allies and that's where the work
that the foreign office is doing in
building those Partnerships in Southeast
Asia and indeed in the Pacific Islands
is so important when you talk about
doing doing stuff as well as the
language what about tech Talk would you
like to see Tick Tock banned from
government phones do you think it will
be the Prime Minister asked me to chair
the defending democracy task force only
a few months ago and that's intended to
defend you as well Jane because uh your
role as you know as a journalist is
essential to democracy just as mine as
an elected official is and so keeping
those of us and indeed many others who
are part of our Democratic Life part of
our Democratic processes free and safe
is absolutely essential there are many
different apps that you can load onto
your phone I haven't personally loaded
Tick Tock for many reasons you can
probably guess but understanding exactly
what the challenges that these apps pose
and what they are asking for and how
they're reaching into our lives is
incredibly important that's why I've
asked the national cyber security Center
to look into this I haven't had an
answer so I'm not going to give you that
answer yet I can't but as soon as I do
you'll I'm sure I'll be seeing uh but if
their advice was that it is a
potentially a threat you would have no
qualms about saying we should all be
taking it off our phones well look the
different countries have taken different
approaches the Indian government has
banned Tick Tock and many other apps the
US government has taken different
choices in terms of their government
phones different states in the United
States have decided to ban them from
different states phones and so different
companies different countries take in
different approaches I mean what's
certainly clear is that for many young
people tick tock is now a news source
and just as it's quite right that we
know who owns the news sources in the UK
whether it's News International or
mirror group or whatever it happens to
be Trinity you know it's important that
we know who owns new sources that are
feeding into our phones and Tick Tock is
one of them it's an excellent way to
lose many hours though I've found in
terms of children
I find that plenty of other ways in
social media indeed indeed
um let's move on to defense spending we
were talking a lot about yesterday with
this integrated review
um 8 billion was the minimum that Ben
Wallace said he required it looks like
it's it's going to be 5 billion at most
now when we take into account the August
money as well that that knocks it down
to about 1.9 million it's not a huge sum
is it do you would you like to have seen
a lot more you know I'm a former Army
officer you're never going to hire me
arguing for less money for defense
that's not afraid that's not in my DNA
um but the reality is this is a huge
increase in defense spending and we've
got to be realistic as to what we're
trying to do here we're trying to
increase our defense spending and and
make sure that we're more capable of the
time when challenges are facing Us in
different ways and you know the orcas
deal isn't just about nuclear boats it's
also about our own domestic security
what it is doing is it's lowering the
cost for each individual boat for the
Royal Navy now that's a hugely important
issue we get more we get more for our
money which is fantastic and it's also
about the way in which we support our
Armed Forces if you look at the second
Battalion the Yorkshire regiment
recently training with drones you're
seeing a very different kind of infantry
to the one I was used to when I was
serving 20 years ago you know 20 years
ago we went into Iraq and I was one of
those soldiers we didn't have drones
we'd you know if you wanted a if you
wanted an overflight you had to wait
hours if you you know if you were lucky
to get an F-16 or or something to go
over you and and to give you a forward
look now infantry battalions are able to
do that from drones that capability is a
real change and demonstrates the
investment that's going in that you talk
about the imagery we speak a little
Danny yes saying and that was his
concern it was the Army he said that
that is what is being hollowed out that
is where the money is gonna should be
going and it doesn't seem that a lot of
this money's going to go there well look
I hope very much that what we're going
to be looking at in terms of the Army is
making sure that we keep getting some of
the most fantastic young people joining
our Armed Forces if you look at the way
in which the British army is able to
recruit and retain some of the most
fantastic individuals in our country and
help them to serve our country in many
many different ways actually I mean we
talk about the front line but of course
floods and many other different areas
the armed forces have been fantastic
it's really inspiring and I was lucky
enough to be in Tracy Crouch's
constituency yesterday and see some of
the work that the rbli are doing in
order to support any number of different
veterans where they're able to serve and
serve again but if if the government
isn't putting a lot of money into the
army could you understand why people
maybe would think twice about coming
into that service well all I can say is
speak from experience on that and say it
was the most fantastic experience for me
I I hugely uh well I got so much out of
the Armed Forces I got so much out of
the army it was it was a fantastic
experience and I hope many young people
will think about it I mean for others
maybe it's the Navy the Air Force maybe
they're all Marines there are many many
different ways of serving and and I can
tell you now as the security minister
and uh responsible for some of our
agencies National Crime agency and
organizations like MI5 offer many many
other ways to serve our country that are
truly inspirational and keep us safe in
ways that sometimes you'll never hear
about but uh but are really
fantastically important before we let
you go the the migration bill of course
I added second reading in the house last
night Theresa May uh made quite a
powerful speech she of course spent six
years at the home office she said that
this legislation on small boats won't
work
um we should be protecting people from
Modern slavery and that this will go
against it do you think we should be
listening to her here I always listen to
Theresa May I think she's a
fantastically important colleague and
actually she's a good friend so I do
listen to her well one of the things
that I've been watching in recent years
and you know I've been speaking to
people in the world food program and
many of our embassies around the world
when I was chairing the Foreign Affairs
committee many of our partners in
different parliaments is that this is a
challenge that we're all facing in
different ways and it's an exploitation
of some of the world's most vulnerable
leading to a level of Cruelty that we
you know is almost impossible to imagine
and we very often quite understandably
focus on that last element that that 20
miles between France and the United
Kingdom that people are trying to cross
actually this is a trade that is
crossing not just France and Italy but
many parts of North Africa leaving quite
literally thousands dead in the Sahara
quite literally thousands dead in the
Mediterranean I don't know whether you
remember Jane but I certainly see it on
my memory that photograph of a land
cardi that young boy who was drowned and
washed off on a Turkish Beach this is a
I mean this human trafficking is is
costing a terrible terrible price it's
possible to to absolutely agree with you
but also say that what Theresa May is
also rides May says it's also right that
it isn't going to protect people the
government's plan isn't going to protect
people from Modern slavery well what's
absolutely clear is that every
government has a responsibility to fight
this appalling crime of human
trafficking there's no question about
that every government also has the
responsibility to see what it can to end
more than slavery and the first thing
you could do to end modern slavery is
separate the those enslaved people from
their captors and that's exactly what
this government's trying to do now there
are huge challenges I'm not I'm not
going to belittle it there's no question
that these are very very difficult
things to do but the first thing we've
got to do is stop this appalling
exploitation of some of the world's most
vulnerable people I'm doing that thank
you very much thank you